I think that race is something that
commie can definitely approach in a
funny way and you can say you know
certain things about the racial
situation in our country I think it's
just like it's it's really it's really
hard like you can definitely do it you
just like can't do it haphazardly you
know you really have to like think about
what you're saying and I think that's
just that's just the way that's just the
way audiences are you know I think
people are really sensitive to that and
whether or not that's right or wrong I
don't know I mean the fact that people
are so sensitive to their racial issues
I don't know if that's cool people like
you know Michael Richards and the whole
like Mel Gibson thing and like Dog the
Bounty Hunter that to me is like
hilarious what what's funny to me about
that is that then those guys have to do
this kind of standard apology routine
where they go into like a rehab and then
they go on like Larry King and then they
start crying and that you know all that
stuff and then they'll go on like
Letterman and just it'll just be like a
stone cold audience reception you know
and there's just a sort of like standard
protocol thing of like when you up
dealing with like you know something
racial like that and all of a sudden it
comes out that you said something really
racist then these guys I'll do the same
thing like so that to me is is you know
hilarious we actually did a sketch about
that this year where pollen Aziz their
characters the illusion ators they do
this magic trick and it ends up being
really racist and they then do the
standard thing that those guys do you
know they just go on talk shows and do
the standard apology and then this
sketch they try to apologize to every
black person in the country like they go
down to the capital and they sit there
with a huge stack of papers and they
just read out every name starting with
the A's and the joke is that they only
got through the A's
just it just took too long so they
couldn't do it so then what they do is
they they get another magician to join
the group and just to appear that
they're not racist they hire a black guy
and it's michael kay williams from the
wire plays Omar on the wire and you know
of course he realizes that okay I'm just
being used to be a magician because I'm
black and you guys are trying to look
like you're not racist so yeah I mean
that was kind of us trying to sort of
poke fun at like what these guys
actually do you know like Dog the Bounty
Hunter come on like you're busted you're
racist call it what you want but you're
busted